I do not believe people are going to
believe that I got an Oscar we all know
winning an Oscar can open up all kinds
of doors you won't believe the doors
he's able to open with a phony gold
statue this video by rock stars
pretending to be an Oscar winner did get
this guy into a couple of VIP parties
and almost into trouble with the law
this is behind the scenes let's go
there's a lot of crazy stuff you didn't
see hi I'm Marc David with new media
rockstars and this is Phillip Melina and
Ted Marsden they directed and produced
the video honestly there's a bunch of
reasons why the shins have worked
look at this big statue I've got this
from the internet let's look here he's
holding a reef do you look at the but
it's very high fit but Rana leg plus we
shot an interview with a duct tape bow
tie Nike running shoes in a jacket with
a missing buck I don't know how people
believe this is the best I could do
I had a little camera crew following
that made us pretty obvious not to get
in trouble but it helps because people
thought they were proper ups there's
money building that process are you
serious
haha everybody was buying it except for
this one white mustache the man he took
a real close look at that Oscar while I
was taking selfies and we met eyes I
panicked
the only thing I could do was wink and
that bought us a little more time until
security actually came and kicked us at
a snack shop so he won't but filming the
whole event not all kinds of assault
almost half and death right out of frame
there's a guy ready that smacks the
Oscar he was reaching his hands out loud
say hey I see you walks away as if he
wasn't just trying to steal our Oscar
physical violence I'm not gonna say that
he was gonna beat me up but he was about
to yeah he could care less that I had an
Oscar all the attention was great there
are some people getting right up in my
space specifically there was this one
guy and giving me the bedroom eyes and
when I had to go to use the bathroom who
needed to use the bathroom the same time
that guy you can understand why I chose
not to take a pee and get out of there
we changed my story throughout the
entire night which although it was a
costume designer costume dude wearing
anything
but the craziest claim that I made was
that I won for Original Song for Selma I
look nothing like calming him John
Legend I get kind of slip up
what's your do we need to go okay we're
trying to go hey guys
we thought there would be a bigger crowd
tonight in Hollywood on Oscar night
winner train people don't want to see
movies yeah we were hoping to get into
the Oscars but that didn't happen so we
settled for the next best thing
news coverage of the ceremony and they
didn't want to deal with me but we did
interrupt that broadcast if you're
wondering if I got in trouble for taking
that car at the valet you should know
that ABC 7 News checked in with LAPD
LAPD telling us it's probably also long
since no complaints is mixed fine thank
you for that and they're not pursuing
any charges because I was five hours
sober before getting in the car and the
owner was cool with him now we did go
back to every establishment and pay for
the items that I got for free but I do
want to point out that I wasn't asking
for stuff all night some people just
wanted to give me stuff like this guy he
gave me cigarettes because he wanted to
celebrate with me I don't smoke I have
asthma we went through two checkpoints
on our way to the dhobi game this was
legit security they were checking for
bombs and cars right next to us we got
stopped before the theater
try to get down to get a drink and then
they sent us this trip
not go to jail you know it's great if
there was a real celebrity a person
might think that they shouldn't bother
them or they don't deserve to approach
them I don't know I
but instead they forget their fears they
muster up the courage and be part of the
fun thanks for watching our video we're
really humbled by the response so please
subscribe to new media rockstars so you
can see more of our pranks crazy social
experiments and everything that we're
gonna bring to you did the only way
you're gonna be able to watch it is by
hitting subscribe guys yeah your job
would you go like
you